and they are going to take on jaime
maria sixth appearance of the season
and he got him with the off-speed pitch
one away
pulled toward third and rendon has got
it
two down three straight sliders he
throws
that is out toward left field and justin
upton has a beat on it
with a quick first inning let's take a
look at the season numbers for jimmy
herget this will be his first start
winning 16 games a nice solid era
speaks very glowingly of herget loves
the attitude he brings 2-2 pitch that's
on the ground down to first and pick
cleanly by guzman the condor to the bag
one away
pretty
uh what's the word conservative on that
first pitch
here's a pop-up on the right side of the
infield
and solac takes care of it too gone
pujol certainly a guy capable of that
the o2 and he pulls this one on the
infield a high hop for tajeda shows off
that arm
good off speed pitch down goes gallow
one away second strikeout for hymic
[Applause]
2-2
guzman pulled the shoot a little bit too
late
oh the swing of the miss got him with a
breaking ball and
the old school thought was bringing in
you you're putting yourself out there
for a big inning going against you but
they're going by percentages they might
have a play at the plate something hit
on the ground
ward lofts went out to right center
field it's a single angels have a
one-nothing lead as taylor ward picks up
his third rbi of the season can't seem
to figure out the other side of it the
3-2 there's a swing and a miss so
fletcher
strikes out it's funny how you play
catch even i do to this day
first couple of them feel good and then
all of a sudden there's that
that one that just goes pop
something here
it's one
two there's a strike and simmons
down looking
stassi and ward the runners this one
popped up third base side
connor falefa appears to have room and
that is out number two and now there are
runners everywhere they're loaded with
two outs here angel's trying to add on
to this one nothing lead and
mike trout will be stepping up to the
plate two two to trout
and that one on the ground third base
kiner falefa to his slide
throws out trout and the inning is done
bauer's second in strikeouts with 83.
calhoun will go down swinging speaking
of strikeouts two outs
upper third in what we called the living
room
this ball wrapped down into the left
field corner
by huff
and he has a double
so huff his first extra base hit in the
big leagues
that's drilled out to left field this
one's got a chance to get out of here
and it does
big fly for albert pujols
[Applause]
661st of his career and he stands alone
in the number five spot all time on the
home run list yeah the machine rolling
by now to say hey kid
387 feet for pull holes
congratulations to albert passing willie
mays on the all-time home front list
661 career home runs to go along with
669 career doubles
and a hug
jeremy reed again loving to see that
from his teammates
how special that is
for albert pujols
wallace cues this one over the third
kind of felipe goes to second base a
little hesitation
and out at second the run scores
push from barrier and a bouncer over the
middle and that one is through base hit
that will get both runners to the plate
and it makes it a one-run game as
calhoun brings home a pair with a hit in
the seventh and how about that
exhale from willy
amazing 661 career home runs 669 career
doubles
that is drilled out to left field
make it 6.62
big fly for albert pujols it's four to
two halos
662 for the machine
wow that ball was crushed he's getting a
chance to play
every day
love seeing now from albert
that's drilled out towards center field
tavares is not going to get there one
hops defense two runs come across rendon
on his way to second it's a two rbi
double
six to two angels
chopper left side simmons has it to
fletcher for one relay back to first
light that baby up as the angels pick up
the victory
by the final of six to two it's good to
see that but albert pujols
at the show on the wheels yesterday
running the bases able to jog around the
bases twice a day